We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
Here's a caller who is not in favor of Joe
Biden.
Listen to what he has to say.
I'm lost.
I just lost a of.
Because you saw the world look at our free
speech TV.
Joe Biden is a market value of the United
States.
You'll be lucky to be free speech TV.
Once you think about that.
Pretty much he has pretty much to the left
wing of the party, which is not even a party
anymore.
It's radical, extremist, leftist.
Thanks, Poppy.
Yeah, listen, Biden is not the authoritarian.
It's Trump who's been hostile to a free press.
It's Trump who's been hostile to media.
It's Trump who's kicked people out of the
press briefing room.
It's Trump who calls media fake news and the
enemy of the people.
Joe Biden.
You can say a lot of negative things about
Joe Biden, and we've said many of them.
Joe Biden is not an authoritarian.
Joe Biden, clearly, much like Barack Obama,
respects and understands the role of a free
and independent press.
And this is how things go backwards.
Trump is one of the most authoritarian and
hostile to media presidents we've had in a
long time.
And people are calling me saying media and
free speech are in trouble.
If Biden wins.
Come on, guys.
You're living in a fantasy world on today's
bonus show.
I am going to tell the story of firefighters
visiting my house at 4:00 a.m. this weekend.
Okay.
Why were they at my house at 4:00 a.m. this
weekend?
I'll tell you on the bonus show.
Make sure to sign up at join Pacman dot com
or by becoming a patron at Patrie on dot com
slash David Pakman QEP.